uh say maybe like a reconstructive lip
one yeah I think your boobs are natural
though something the way they like move
[Music]
I think you've had a boob job so that's
gonna be at least one plastic surgery a
butt lift maybe like a little cheek
lifter face-to-face
I'll say a butt lift like a liquid Rhino
because like the produnos is so like
perfectly shaped I don't know if you've
had that many you I think you might just
be God's favorite obvious it felt good
they know they thought I was cute
your nose and your chin maybe
maybe some cheek I don't want to say
breast augmentation but so many people
have their boobs on so many people yeah
all right I think the nose but other
than that maybe not that much I don't
know unless you're hiding something all
right
breast augmentation yeah maybe that
maybe something body wise like lipo a
tuck that was interesting I'm a pretty
like modest person and I don't try to
draw attention to myself
foreign
[Music]
I do not think you've had any notable
cosmetic plastic surgery
[Music]
well say BBL yeah maybe
some chest yeah some breast augmentation
your nose and maybe your jawline more on
them
more surgery sign you know what I was
very flattered that people were
questioning whether I had a lot of
plastic surgeries that I did not have I
thought that was a cute fun moment I
love that for me
I think you have a nose job I think so
too a good chin surgery I'm not sure if
it's like like a lipo or like a
reconstructive one but something like
something maybe like a reconstructive
lip one yeah I think your boobs are
natural though
[Laughter]
we said you probably most yes I'm Gonna
Be the Anchor over here I'm gonna put
myself
foreign
I think that you should be towards that
end I don't I don't think you've had as
much plastic surgery okay we have to
switch okay I think Kelly higher higher
yeah than me yeah but I think you should
come yeah right there in the middle I
definitely think I've had more than you
though yeah yeah listen I just believe
that you guys that's okay I'll just be
in the middle right here I think I might
move you up I think above all right
think about me oh but now oh wait but
now I don't know it doesn't matter this
isn't unified I mean I only said one for
you so you think it's okay too too do
you think we should I think we should
okay okay
how dangerous do you think it is to get
a BBL I would say it definitely
influenced my decision when I was like
researching it that's all I'll say
interesting yeah let's just say it
influenced my decision maybe we should
move you down the line then
because of like the high prevalence now
I don't think it's as dangerous as they
used to be if you were a girl your
answer would have made me move you more
in this direction okay but I also think
that your answer leads me to believe
that you have had more plastic surgery
yeah I agree I was surprised but also
not surprised that I was the only male
here but once again like the whole
stigma of plastic surgery okay so what
does everyone do for a living I own a
business e-commerce I work in porn yeah
I have my porn I own a beauty school I'm
an actress and I do digital marketing
I'm a pastor I'm a student and a fashion
designer so now I work at a ice cream
shop but I was at a strip club I'm a
student I think that you should be you
should move two spaces down why do you
think that because you're a stripper
well I just said strip club I was
actually a shotgirl you having worked in
a sex industry space makes you more
likely to have gotten plastic surgery I
think that if I was not making a living
off of social media I wouldn't have
gotten plastic surgery it's not
something that I regret at all and I'm
not going to be upset to have this
appearance whenever I'm done working in
social media when you guys did get your
surgeries the insurance cover it or did
you pay for it mine was covered for the
most part mine was covered I had
partials oh partial now I feel like I
should go on your other side yeah
maybe you and I should switch them
does anyone have kids we're all like hmm
I do I do wait no because this changes
everything those look natural those look
like naturally big ones how old is
everybody I'm 30. I'm 33 28 23 25 21 30
20. what age was everyone when they got
like their first or their only the first
time that I got plastic surgery I was
29. oh so recently okay I was 31 19. I
was 20 like five days away from being
21. 19. I was 29 so one year ago oh I
was 20 and I'm still 20. um I was under
24 months you might also be third third
let's go he only had just one come on
down
has anyone experienced any stigma or
stereotypes based on their choices
a lot of people think that Asian people
get surgery to look whiter and I don't
think that's true it's the most untrue
stereotype and I think it really sucks
plus there's different beauty standards
in Asia so to be saying that you look
like a white person just doesn't it make
any sense either so I honestly think
that if I were to get plastic surgery in
the future or if you know anyone were to
I don't think your eccentric Beauty
Center should be held to a point where
where they should it should be to the
most of where they feel comfortable and
not letting those standards you know
influence them as much it's a hard thing
though I feel like like when we see
people like I don't see people with like
facial features like me very often in
Hollywood and American Media and things
like that who else faces stigma for sure
I do because you know I'm a mom so like
the first thing my my family's like no
like I should just be worried about my
children and you know the risks that are
involved they didn't want me to go under
I sometimes feel that guilt like I make
the right choice doing that was I being
selfish when I did that I needed to do
it for myself because I didn't like the
person that I was looking at every time
I look in the mirror would anyone get
more I guess I would get more I wouldn't
I would say just because of what I
learned I wouldn't do it again and would
have experienced myself
but what did you learn the self-love
part that's really sweet yeah I
purposely just wouldn't because I don't
have the fundage for that so I would
do another surgery
mine was more of a medically informed
decision I think it's something that I
considered prior to
some information but thought oh I would
never do that and then
when I was presented different facts
about my body I chose to do certain
things I think that the two of you
should switch because the way that
you're talking about all this I think
you have only had plastic surgery done
once and I feel like you might have had
two procedures whatever reason you got
plastic surgery might have been
something ongoing that resulted in you
getting procedures in two different
spans of time potential
and maybe let's adjust and move you up
to the second in line I think let's do a
little switch around I feel like you
should go in front of Emma though let's
be buddies I disagree but we'll go I
think I need to go back down guys oh I
think before me I really do yeah I would
switch two of y'all okay
okay I'm good with this
thank you
and the big spot we have
Ahmad
I knew it also with one surgery we have
Jordan
two surgeries we have Jessica
okay
Amber with three surgeries
Sabrina also afraid with
talking stars
with five
and second Emma with ten
in first Cassidy was 15. what wow you
know what that should have clicked
earlier I had a major septoplasty also I
had a deviated septum um and also like
there was like a growth so they had to
just like adjust my septum I had a
breast reduction in 2021 so I went from
a size 30 J to I think I'm a 32 e
wow so yeah my back was hurting all the
time thank you in 2020 I found out that
I have a genetic mutation called bracket
2 and I learned about this after my mom
and my aunt both had breast cancer last
year I had a preventative double
mastectomy and then this February I had
reconstructive surgery I found out that
through my health care provider they
only do 10 preventative surgeries like
that in a year it was an emotional
Journey but one that I looked back on
and I'm proud that I did what I did I
had breast augmentation and then just
last month I got it taken out as time
goes by I see all these confident women
with no boobs I made that impulsive
decision like hey I want these out I'm
engaged now I don't need this look I
don't work in a strip club anymore so I
got a mommy makeover almost two years
ago I got a breast lift and a tummy tuck
and about four months ago I got a breast
augmentation okay so my first procedure
was the double eyelid surgery then after
that I got my jaw shaved and then my
third one was the Google fat removal and
then the fourth one was a laser lipo I
got it done I regret it and then the
fifth one is kybella to try to revise it
kybella filler basically all over my
face and then all at once I got jawline
lipo local fat removal 360 lipo arm lipo
and then I got it all injected into my
ass with the BBL I was born with a
bilateral cleft lip and Palette so I've
had 15 total revisions I had a bone
graft when I was 12. I had double jaw
surgery when I was 15. I have cheek
implants and I had liposuction under my
jaw oh
my boobs are natural
everyone has a face mine didn't form
correctly I was born with a birth defect
I don't know what I look like I get to
almost kind of help create that and be
my most ideal self if you are like not
feeling good like let people know like
if you need a surgery that could be
considered elective or it's a plastic
surgery like you're a best Advocate your
your own Advocate keep baking almond
effort to make yourself feel at your
best and don't let anything take it take
its toll on you I think if you're
considering getting a surgery done make
sure to research research research but
my boobs are natural as well